bei uns ist nun wie am Anfang schon
angekündigt der CDU Außenpolitiker und
Oberst ad Roderich Kiesewetter hallo
hallo Frau jung grüße sie schön dass Sie
bei uns sind sie setzen sich schon lange
für mehr Unterstützung für die Ukraine
ein sie haben jetzt vor dem NATO
Außenministertreffen auch dazu
aufgerufen die Ukrain Hilfen deutlich
auszuweiten haben im Beitrag gerade
gehört dass Deutschland also in einer
Haushaltskrise ist das wussten wir auch
schon vorher massiv Probleme hat Geld
eben für diverse Projekte aufzubringen
doch der Topf das haben wir im Beitrag
gelernt für die ukra der bleibt
unangetastet und sie sagen sie wollen
die Hilfen sogar noch ausweiten da kann
man doch jetzt aber nicht von geringer
Unterstützung von Seiten Deutschlands
sprechen oder nun ein Großteil unserer
Unterstützung Frau jung fast 65% ist die
Unterstützung ukrainischer Flüchtlinge
in Deutschland und gerade mal 15%
unserer Unterstützung ist militärische
Unterstützung das sind noch nicht mal 4
Milliarden Euro an Waffen die geliefert
wurden und dazu vorrangig
Flugabwehrsysteme zum Schutz der Städte
aber nur sehr wenig nicht für die
kämpfende Truppe vor Ort sie haben es ja
selbst angesprochen vier Raketenwerfer
14 panzerhaauitzen 18 Kampfpanzer und 80
Marder auf einer Länge von Flensburg bis
Mailand und ähnlich sind die
Unterstützungen unserer Nachbarstaaten
das heißt wenn wir sagen wir sind der
zweitgrößte Unterstützer der Ukraine
liegt das vorrangig an der sozialen
Unterstützung der Flüchtlinge in
Deutschland und je mehr Flüchtlinge
kommen umso größer unsere Unterstützung
gut ist aber dass der
Verteidigungsminister sehr klar deutlich
macht dass es hier nicht um ein Krieg
Russland gegen die Ukraine geht sondern
dass wir alle gefordert sind deswegen
hat er auch deutlich gemacht dass die
Bundeswehr kriegsfähig werden muss falls
oder kriegstauglich falls der Krieg sich
ausweitet was absehbar ist wenn die
Ukraine zerfallen sollte s haben den
Verteidigungsminister gerade
angesprochen er hat sich geäußert heute
zu diversen Themen wir haben auch eben
gerade etwas schon davon angesprochen
eine Sache möchte ich auch gerne
aufgreifen also wir haben über diesen
bildartikel schon eben mit den beiden
Korrespondenten gesprochen diese
sogenannten geheimppläne von beid und
Scholz und dort in diesem Artikel wurden
auch sie zitiert mit folgendem Satz man
liefert bewusst nicht das was die
Ukraine zur Befreiung von besetzten
Territorium braucht wie Taurus oder
weitere Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 sondern
beschränkt sich auf die Verteidigung
einer rumpfukraine wenn sie sagen
bewusst damit unterstellen sie ja auch
der Bundesregierung einen konkreten Plan
was wiederum der Verteidigungsminister
abwegigen Unsinn nennt ich unterstelle
das nicht nur ich kann es auch belegen
entscheidend ist dass in der
Bundesregierung uneinigkeit herrscht der
Verteidigungsminister sagt ähnlich wie
die Außenministerin dass die Ukraine
gewinnen muss der Bundeskanzler sagt die
Ukraine darf nicht verlieren aber
Russland darf auch nicht gewinnen das
ruft nach
Waffenstillstandslinie und wir hören und
sehen sehenden Auges wie Russland
Versorgungslinien auf die Krim baut über
80% der russischen militärunterstützung
läuft nun mal über die Krim und wenn man
die Krim von den Versorgungslinien
abschneiden W würde müssten die
russischen Truppen über kurz oder lang
dort aufgeben und die einzigen
westlichen Waffensysteme die dies
könnten wären die Taurus weil sie eine
Reichweite haben die an die russischen
Eisenbahnlinien aber auch an die
kerzchbrücke kommen und das
Verteidigungsministerium war dafür
liberale Grüne sind dafür das
Außenministerium möchte es aber das
Kanzleramt verhindert es und das ist
genau das was sie eben auch Ansprachen
die Amerikaner erwarten den Punkt mehr
den Elm tevissen ansprach oder auch was
Herr Scherding vorhin im Netz sagte wir
sind uns über die Kriegsziele nicht im
klar und ich glaube wir müssen sehr
deutlich machen Russland muss verlieren
lernen das heißt das Existenzrecht der
Nachbarn anerkennen keiner will Russland
militärisch schlagen aber Sie müssen das
Existenzrecht der Nachbarn anerkennen
und die Ukraine muss ihre Grenzen von 91
wiederherstellen sonst wird das
russische Vorgehen zur Blaupause bei
Serbien gegenüber Kosovo Iran Irak oder
das große Bild der Allianz von China
Russland Nordkorea Iran das ist nämlich
dass Taiwan dann von China einverleibt
wird also die Stärke des Westens die
Ukraine in ihren Grenzen von ein 90 zu
erhalten wird auch daran gemessen ob es
uns gelingt oder ob das Recht des
Stärkeren sich durchsetzt gegen die
Stärke des Rechts dazu passt eine Frage
bei uns im Stream die ich gesehen habe
und da heißt es die Frage ist doch was
ist Sieg in diesem Konflikt dass
Russland aus der Ukraine einschließlich
Krim vertrieben wird sich Putin
öffentlich entschuldigt und
Reparationszahlungen fließen was glauben
Sie nun in jedem Fall geht es darum dass
die Ukraine ihre Grenzen von 91
wiederherstellen kann dazu gehört die
Krim und dazu gehört der Donbass
selenski war ja bereit zu verhandeln vor
den furchtbaren Kriegsverbrechen bis in
den März hinein hat er Angeboten auf die
Krim zu verzichten auf die
natomitgliedschaft zu verzichten hat um
Reparationen gebeten aber eben auch um
EU-Mitgliedschaft und mit den
furchtbaren Kriegsverbrechen und der
Aussage Russlands wir haben die Zeit ihr
habt die Uhr und eure Uhr läuft ab war
klar dass Russland gar nicht verhandeln
will und Russland hat ja im Vorfeld des
Krieges deutlich gemacht dass es ihnen
darum geht die alte Sowjetunion zu
restaurieren indem die baltischen
Staaten kein Recht haben in der NATO und
in der EU zu sein und dass die Ukraine
wie Weißrussland belaruss kein
Existenzrecht außerhalb der
russländischen Föderation haben diese
Ziele hat Russland nicht aufgegeben und
deshalb ist ein Sieg der Ukraine ein
Sieg des Rechts und es geht eben darum
dass dann wir auch im Kauf nehmen dass
das russische System sich neu orientiert
klar und wenn die Krim fällt ist Putins
Schicksal im Grunde besiegelt wir haben
ja gesehen wie auf Druck reagiert als
prigosin auf dem Marsch nach Moskau war
dann hat er einen Verhandler
eingeschaltet Lukaschenko und dann hat
prigoschin sein Vorgehen
deutlich reduziert aber auch sein Leben
verloren also Putin muss unter Druck
geraten und das geschieht wenn die
russischen Truppen auf der Krim aufgeben
müssen keiner will sie umbringen gehen
wir noch mal ganz konkret auf die
Waffenlieferung auf die Situation an der
Front ein ich habe es angesprochen der
Verteidigungsminister der hat sich heute
auch zu dem Thema tauruslieferung aus
Deutschland auf eine Journalistenfrage
geäußert die auch sie immer wieder
fordern wir hören mal kurz zusammen
rein es gibt keine dem Taurus
Marschflugkörper
ähnlichen Flug marschfugkörper die von
anderen geliefert worden sind weder die
amerikanische
Cam mit einer Reichweite von 165 km noch
Storm Shadow noch das französische
Modell haben eine auch nur annäherend
vergleichbare Reichweite wie die Taurus
zum zweiten hat es mir gegenüber in der
Ukraine keine offizielle Anfrage nach
Taurus Lieferung gegeben in dem Gespräch
was ich geführt habe weil die Kollegen
auf der ukrainischen Seite wissen dass
die Position der Ukraine der Position
der Bundesregierung nach wie vor die ist
die ich ihn geschildert habe es gibt
keinen neuen Sachstand kleine Korrektur
die Antwort hat er gegeben bei der
regierungsbefragung war keine
Journalistenfrage aber wir haben es
gerade gehört also Pistorius sagte wir
wären die ersten und einzigen die Waffen
mit so einer Reichweite liefern und er
sagte vor allem auch es gäbe keine
offizielle Anfrage der Ukraine nach
Taurus wieso sind sie dann der Meinung
dass also Taurus dort so dringend
gebraucht würde das ist ja nicht richtig
was gerade berichtet wurde er ist nicht
gefragt worden aber es gibt offizielle
Anfragen an das Bundeskanzleramt Taurus
zu liefern und die wurden abschlägig
beschieden warum soll sich ein
Verteidigungsminister in der Ukraine
oder ein selenski eine Abfuhr holen wenn
er weiß dass der Bundeskanzler ist
ablehnt und er hat ja auch gesagt
offiziell wurde nicht darüber gesprochen
wir wissen alle dass inoffiziell
natürlich informell über solche Fragen
gesprochen wird und ich weiß auch dass
der Verteidigungsminister ein sehr
großer Befürworter einer solcher lief
solchen Lieferung wäre aber das Kanzler
möchte es nicht und er hat ja auch
herausgestellt warum dieses System hat
eine Reichweite die ein bisschen also
bisschen weniger als doppelt so weit ist
wie die Verwandten Storm Shadow und Skyp
die haben alle dieselbe Firma die die
herstellt und diese Firma hat diese drei
Typen ausgeliefert die Bundesrepublik
bestand darauf Reichweiten mit etwa 500
km zu bekommen weil wir keine eigene
Luftüberlegenheit haben Franzosen und
Briten haben stärkere Luftwaffen als wir
und wir haben deshalb abstandswaffen
gewählt und jetzt ist das Fatale dass
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland die als
einzige über so ein System außerhalb der
Amerikaner verfügen dieses System der
Ukraine verweigern und wir sehen den
Auges die russischen
versorgungslieferungen sehen und wir
werden die einzigen die da helfen können
und das ist ja das Bittere und ich spüre
aus den Worten des
Verteidigungsministers auch eher die
Verbitterung dass wir das nicht liefern
können und wir haben es ein Ausweg wäre
es beispielsweise den Britten und
Franzosen zur Verfügung zu stellen dass
sie es dann liefern oder den Amerikanern
oder dass die Produktion noch einmal
angeworfen wird aber das entscheidend
ist dass wir unterlassene Hilfeleistung
erbringen und diesen Vorwurf muss sich
das Bundeskanzleramt wirklich gefallen
lassen weil hier das unnötig
Menschenleben kostet unnötig die Ukraine
um Dinge bettelt die selbstverständlich
sind nämlich alles zu tun und dann merkt
man eben auch dass der deutsche Spruch
aus dem kanzelamt wir unterstützen die
Ukraine solange es nötig ist und wir
unterstützen sie in ihrer Verteidigung
nicht bedeutet dass es um die
Wiederherstellung der Grenzen von 91
geht und auch nicht bedeutet dass die
Ukraine gewinnen soll hier ist die
Regierung uneinig und wird durch die
Richtlinienkompetenz des Kanzlers
gelähmt würden sie dann soweit gehen
weil diese Frage habe ich hier gerade
von einem User Userin Oberberg gelesen
weil eben nicht F16 oder Taurus z.B
geliefert würden will die Nato nicht
dass Ukraine gewinnt und alles endlich
beendet wird und wenn ja warum nun das
Entscheidende ist ja dass wir uns über
die Kriegsziele einigen und das Lösen
nicht einzelne Waffensysteme sondern es
sind drei wesentliche Punkte erstens
dass die Versprechen die gemacht werden
auch eingehalten werden die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat sehr viel
versprochen aber die meisten Lieferung
kommen erst Ende nächstes Jahr das ist
wahrscheinlich viel zu spät zweitens
dass die Ukraine eine Perspektive in EU
und NATO hat und das nicht argumentiert
wird wie man das aus Teilen der
deutschen Regierung hört dass eine
Einladung in die NATO eine Eskalation
für Putin bedeuten würde Putin eskaliert
ja die ganze Zeit gerade wo wir so wenig
liefern also die Perspektive NATO und EU
und das dritte ist dass sehr ehrlich
unsere Bevölkerung darauf auch
aufmerksam gemacht wird was der
Verteidigungsminister mit einem sehr
klugen Schachzug begonnen hat wir müssen
unsere un Bevölkerung ehrlich aufklären
wenn die Ukraine fällt kommen 10 bis 15
Millionen weitere Menschen nach Europa
nach Mitteleuropa sie verlassen das
osteuropäische Land und davon werden 3
bis 4 Millionen nach Deutschland kommen
das ist viel teurer wir haben ja über
die Zahlen gesprochen 60% Sozialleistung
in der deutschen Unterstützung der
Ukraine viel teurer als jetzt mit einem
erheblichen militärischen Aufwand die
Ukraine zu befehen dass sie wenigstens
nicht die Fehler wiederholen muss die
wir sie ins letzte Jahr gebracht haben
und in diesem Jahr zu wenig Munition
zu wenig Kampfpanzer zu wenig
Schützenpanzer und Artillerie sie
braucht deutlich mehr das hat saluschni
deutlich gemacht und auch kleba aber
diese drei Punkte sind zu erfüllen die
klare Perspektive alle Waffen die nötig
sind und vor allen Dingen die
Vorbereitung unserer Bevölkerung dass
wir nicht aus der Westentasche und
nebenbei im Sommerurlaub so einen Krieg
aushalten werden das Lieferungen zu spät
kam das haben wir auch schon mal erlebt
schauen wir mal gemeinsam auf einen
Zeitraffer des Frontverlaufs seit Beginn
des russischen Angriff angriffskriegs
hier kann man jetzt sehen wie quasi
zunächst russische Truppen in orange
hier gekennzeichnet auf dem Vormarsch
waren zurückgedrängt worden sind und man
sieht also da ist viel Bewegung drin am
Anfang natürlich ganz viel und da jetzt
besonders erst im Osten und im Süden und
dann stagniert es jetzt das haben wir
auch gesehen also am Anfang ganz viel
Bewegung dann eben immer weniger wir
haben es also auch am Anfang der Sendung
ja schon angesprochen größere Gebiet
gebietszur Gewinne sind Gelände Gewinne
sind gar nicht mehr gemacht worden ist
es denn überhaupt realistisch mit jetzt
auch all dem was Sie gesagt haben was
was man dafür bräuchte aber ist es
realistisch Russland in absehbarer Zeit
zurückdräen zu können nun die Ukraine
hat seit Kriegsbeginn nachdem die großen
Eroberungen Russlands waren mehr als 50%
des besetzten Gebietes wieder befreit
und das haben sie mit mangelnder
Unterstützung aus dem Westen geleistet
und wenn wir jetzt mehr tun als nur wir
unterstützen solange wie es nötig ist
sondern mit so viel wie möglich so rasch
wie möglich auch unserer Bevölkerung
deutlich machen dass das eine
Rückversicherung ist für uns selbst dann
hat die Ukraine jede Chance diesen Krieg
zu gewinnen und das sollten wir auch
deutlich machen und anerkennen was die
Ukraine hier bisher geleistet hat wir
sollten ihr auch Vertrauen und wir
müssen auch an einen Faktor denken dass
Hunderttausende männliche Ukrainer im
whrfähigen Alter ihr Land verlassen
haben hier gilt es auch zu appellieren
dass Sie mithelfen dass nicht die
Menschen an der Front verbluten sondern
dass sie entlastet werden das frisch
ausgebildetes Personal an der Front
unterstützt allein in Deutschland leben
über 200.000 whrfähige junge ukrainische
Männer oder Junge werrfähige zwischen 16
und 60 hier geht es also auch darum dass
wir mithelfen dass diese in ihr
Heimatland zurückkehren und dort
beispielsweise bei Feuerwehr helfen im
Katastrophenschutz sie müssen ja nicht
an die Front aber Sie müssen mithelfen
dass die ukrainische Gesellschaft das
ganze übersteht wir können es nicht aus
der Westentasche leisten und wir müssen
auch deutlich machen dass ist mit einer
bestimmten Haltung zu verbinden nämlich
der whrfähigkeit und whrhaftigkeit ich
komme gerade aus USA und aus Kanada wo
mir sehr deutlich klar gemacht wurde die
Amerikaner wollen mehr tun sie erwarten
aber mehr Entlastung der Europäer es ist
ein Krieg auf europäischem Boden und die
Amerikaner werden nach wie vor
unterstützen wenn Sie Ihre Grenzfrage im
Süden also eine Mauer nach Mexiko gelöst
haben aber es geht darum auch Trump zu
verhindern und wir haben es in der Hand
und es wäre furchtbar wenn in einem Jahr
nach den US-Wahlen gesagt würde Trump
sagt das ist ein europäischer Krieg ihr
habt nur ein Drittel von dem geleistet
was die Amerikaner geleistet haben ich
entziehe euch die Unterstützung und auch
den nuklearen Schutzschirm wir haben es
in der Hand auch unsere Sicherheit mit
einer starken Unterstützung der Ukraine
zu verbessern und glaubwürdige
transatlantische Lastenteilung ja
vorzuleben zum Schluss möchte ich gerne
noch eine Frage aus dem Stream an Sie
stellen sie kommt von Oliver Sassendorf
und er fragt sich früher oder später
wird es zu Verhandlungen kommen warum
denn nicht schon jetzt oder braucht der
Westen noch ein paar hundert Hektar mehr
um in eine bessere Verhandlungsposition
in um in einer besseren
Verhandlungsposition zu sein dieser User
glaubt also an die Verhandlung was
würden sie dem Antworten der Herr
Sassendorf berührt ja ein Punkt der die
deutsche Bevölkerung im weiten Maße
betrifft weil auch zu wenig erklärt wird
die Ukraine wollte immer und immer
wieder verhandeln und Russland hat
deutlich gemacht dass sie die ganze
Ukraine wollen und ja auch auf dem Weg
dorthin waren Putin möchte nicht
verhandeln weil er nicht verhandeln
braucht es geht ihm einfach darum Terror
Angst und Schrecken zu verbreiten und
vor allen Dingen zu zeigen dass er in
einer win-winsituation ist wenn die
Ukraine fällt gehen Millionen von
Menschen raus dann werden die
Europawahlen zu einem echten Problem
werden innenpolitisch und Verhandlungen
dazu gehören zwei über was soll denn die
Ukraine verhandeln über die Rückgabe von
20.000 entführten Kindern die mit neuem
Geburtsdatum und neuem Namen zur
Adoption freigegeben wurden über
tausende vergewaltigte Frauen über
hunderte kastrierte Männer über
ermordete Schulklassen über ermordete
Schwangere über was sollen sie
verhandeln und vor allen Dingen welche
Sicherheitsgarantien bekommen Sie dass
Russland nicht weiter angreift deshalb
da Russland seine Kriegsziele nicht
aufgegeben hat muss die Botschaft ganz
klar lauten die Ukraine verhandelt wenn
sie ihr Gebiet befreit hat und es geht
darum dass es Sicherheitsgarantien gibt
dass Russland das Existenzrecht all
seiner Nachbarstaaten anerkennt das
müssen die Verhandlungspunkte sein und
der Abzug der russischen Nuklearwaffen
aus Kaliningrad die unsere
Friedensbewegung überhaupt nicht stört
die russischen Truppen ins Transnistrien
und Georgien wir müssen das große Paket
schnüren weil Russland uns sonst in
einen großen Krieg einwickelt sagt CDU
Außenpolitiker Roderich Kiesewetter er
sagt wir haben es in der Hand vielen
Dank dass Sie bei uns zu Gast waren
vielen Dank für die Einladung danke
schön